>> Neil: WHAT MAKES SOMETHING
FAKE NEWS?
I WOULD ASSUME IF THE NEWS BEING
REPORTED IS FAKE AND WRONG, THAT
IS BAD.
HOW ABOUT THE NEWS BEING
REPORTED MY COLLEAGUE HAS
DISCOVERED AGAIN THE PRESIDENT
DOESN'T DISTINGUISH.
APPARENTLY FURIOUS OVER
INTERVIEW WITH HOUSE MINORITY
LEADER STEVE SCALISE.
DOES THE PRESIDENT LIKE STEVE
FOR THAT QUITE LIKE LET'S SAY HE
DOESN'T LIKE CHRIS FOR
CHALLENGING
CHALLENGIN SCALISE ON THAT.
SAY WHAT YOU WILL ABOUT THE
WITNESSES, THEY WERE AT CARRARA,
CAREER SERVICE OFFICERS WHO
WORKED IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, OR WHERE SCALISE
SAID HE WAS ONLY INTERESTED IN C
SAID HE WAS ONLY INTERESTED IN R
SAID HE WAS ONLY INTERESTED IN U
SAID HE WAS ONLY INTERESTED IN T
SAID HE WAS ONLY INTERESTED IN N
UKRAINE, A CALL THAT SCALIS
A DOZEN PEOPLE LISTENING IN AND
THE NUMBER OF THEM IMMEDIATELY
UPSET.
WE CAN DEBATE WHETHER THE CRIME
WAS COMMITTED HERE OR ANY CRIME
WAS COMMITTED HERE, BUT CHRIS
CHALLENGED ({FLUSH
THAT WAS HIS VIEW OF WHAT THEY
SAID, THAT IS NOT WHAT THEY SAI
SAID.
PASSIONS RUN DEEP THESE DAYS,
BUT FACTS SHOULD RUN DEEPER.
EVEN IF THOSE VERY FACTS CAN
ELICIT WILDLY DIFFERENT
REACTION, SOME INSISTING THEY
EXONERATE THE RESIDENT AND
OTHERS ADAMANT SAY THEY ALL BUT
INDICT THE PRESIDENT.
IT'S A PITY THE PRESIDENT DIDN'T
STICK TO CHRIS JUST AS
AGGRESSIVELY AS GOING AFTER
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMEN AND
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY MEMBER
JIM HINES AND THE LACK OF ANY
FIRST-HAND EVIDENCE INDICATING
THE PRESIDENT IN ANYTHING.
WHILE IT'S UNDERSTANDABLE NOT TO
LIKE WHAT YOU HEAR,
MR. PRESIDENT, IT'S NOT
UNDERSTANDABLE TO TUNE OUT WHAT
YOU SHOULD OTHERWISE LIKE TOO
HERE, INCLUDING PLENTY OF
COVERAGE OF MARKETS THAT ARE
SOARING AND AN ECONOMY THAT'S
HUMMING.
CHRIS HAS COVER THAT, I HAVE
COVERED THAT, FOX NEWS AND
FOX NEWS BUSINESS -- WHICH IF
YOU DON'T GET COMMUTE SHOULD
DEMAND, NOT SOME OF IT, ALL OF
IT, SOME OF IT AND THE THINGS
YOU MIGHT NOT LIKE THAT YOU ARE
NOT THE
FIRST PRESIDENT TO SAY THE MEDIA
HAS IT OUT FOR YOU.
NO LESS THAN IMPRESSED DARLING
JOHN F. KENNEDY HIMSELF HAD HIS
MOMENTS WITH THE MEDIA.
THINGS WILL SEEP THINGS THROUGH
THE OWN PRISM OF THEIR BELIEFS.
I GET THAT.
LIKE I GET PLENTY OF TRUMP
SUPPORTERS TO CALL ME A NEVER
TRUMPER TO GET IN MATTERS THEY
DON'T LIKE AND PLENTY OF NEVER
TRUMPERS THEMSELVES NEVER GIVING
ANY CREDIT TO A PRESIDENT THEY
WON'T LIKE.
WE CAN'T PLEASE ALL.
THE BEST WE CAN DO AS
JOURNALISTS IS TO BE FAIR TO
ALL, INCLUDING YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT.
THAT'S NOT FAKE DOING THAT.
WHAT IS FAKE IS NOT DOING THAT
BUT WHAT IS FAKE IS SAYING FOX
NEVER USED TO DO THAT.
MR. PRESIDENT, WE HAVE ALWAYS
DONE THAT.
WE DID, CHRIS DID, I KNOW I DID.
I RECALL A CHAT I HAD WITH YOU
BACK IN 2015 WHEN YOU ARE
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
YOU ARE NONE TOO PLEASED,
ACTUALLY CALLED ME NANCY.
THE NEW
NASTY.
THE INTERVIEW, EVEN WORSE.
YOU'RE ENTITLED TO THAT OPINION.
SOME WOULD GO FAR IS THAT I'M
FAT, MR. PRESIDENT?
THE JOURNALIST, THE MATTER THEIR
WEIGHT, ARE NOT ENTITLED TO
PRAISE YOU BUT WE ARE ENTITLED
TO BE FAIR TO YOU.
EVEN IF IT RISKED INVITING YOUR
WRATH.
YOU ARE FREE TO RAGE.
ALL WE ARE FREE TO DO IS REPORT.
AND LET THE VIEWERS DECIDE.
WE STARTED OUT THAT WAY.